ladies
Billy Crystal
I just wanted to make sure I got here
that's why I had the LAPD plant me here
so
all right edgy that's a speeding ticket
for me well welcome to the Oscars or as
ABC likes to call it Regis is night off
wonderful night
posture up who will win the five films
nominated for Best Picture are
yep it's a feel-good retro movie of the
year
3 my is the place to be
Tom Hanks is there but he can't pee then
as he walked his late night watch the
milk talk dark and handsome guy grabbed
his crotch
white lights last rites
sponge dry you fry don't get me wrong
but it was a little bit long
three hours tell me why you know
thank you
Vice President Gore loved the Green Mile
he just wanted to know why the electric
chair couldn't have been solar so
we have a lovely crowd here tonight so
many new faces some just new eyes but a
lot of new faces looking out of the
crowd some exciting stories tonight
great Richard Farnsworth sitting right
over there
welcome
for the straight story which is the
story of dr. Laura Schlessinger
couldn't be here tonight couldn't get
anyone town to do a hair and makeup also
great performance Hilary Swank
who is nominated in the new category
Best Performance by a leading actress
with a supporting part that's a new new
category and we could not have a show
without the man himself who found the
missing Oscars willy full gear sitting
right over there
Willie got $50,000 in finding the 52
Arctic Oscars it's not a lot of money
when you realize that Miramax and
DreamWorks are spending millions of
dollars just to get one
so welcome willing another great story
this year was the sixth sense in the
success of the great young actor Haley
Joel Osment who's sitting right over
there Haley
Gotham
eleven years old god I've had movies and
development longer than that
le this one is for you people kids who
see dead people
are the spookiest people
in the world
eleven having chats with folks in heaven
so if you see my uncle Doug tell him I
didn't pull the plug
you see things that ain't hair like
Bruce Willis with hair you're in the
sixth
you were so rating the 6s you may go
home with Oscar and
it share
I'm gonna don't win 60 minutes I am
gonna go in 60 minutes I'm gonna go and
spill my guts at 60 minutes at 60
minutes I will tell them everything I
know I just don't think they put it on
the show cause I hate to risk my life by
saying that I'm gonna be on 60 minutes
and then tuning in to find out I'm not
even there
it's just Mike Wallace on an empty chair
until I kind of keep it in so I am gonna
tell the truth and say you've done I
just pray to God they had the best run
at someone's held on you and he has got
to do it even though I know I've got my
faults I know everybody there thinks I'm
a loony they have got the nerve they
hire an Andy Rooney hey it really Rolly
safer I'm gonna sing the 60 Minutes
walls you can tell the big sets up at
B&W I've got some information that will
trouble you spare us from your kitchen
you know cigarette addiction is the
thing that fills your vaults I don't
care if they'll say that I'm a wacko
watch this little wacko bring down big
tobacco I'm a part of the insider yes
and I just hang the 60 Minutes Wolfson
I'd like to sing a song about Mike okay
he never met a script that he didn't
like anybody
he's made a lot of movies first Alfie
that he kept on making more he won for
Woody Allen but why'd you have to go and
make choice for how many movies can one
actor make
you'll make one in the next station
break
tonight you're dressed to kill and you
may be going home to Prince of Maine
I gladly cross a bridge too far to be
the actor that you are you're such a
classy
I'm a star okay
he just turned 40 but he digs a team
loves to shower
never gets clean
the guy next door is a closeted marine
that's why this beauty is a champion
there's always roses all over the floor
he gets his referred from Mac nutcase
kid next door
his wife's adulterant and looking for
more that's why this beauty is a champ
he's now a free fresh high hamburger
sellin cat he's lifting weights
throwing plates she fled he's dead
it ain't a feel-good
but boy is it great
that's why this movie
and 1/8
it's time for Oscar
this guy's had work done he never shows
his age
he's 72
I bet wine
that is why the Oscar that's why Oscar
is a change
yes
you